Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now we've got a mission ahead of us,
We have to go and get the materials
for the hatching enzymes,
for these eggs.
Now, some people in the comments said
that they were in this area
But I actually traversed this area
and there doesn't seem to be anything besides the
creatures that are here
And some small
bits of Fauna and flora.
like the things that allow me to have oxygen
Now the- the required materials are as follows as the such (wut?)
Gabe's Feather,
Sea crown,
Membrane tree,
Rouuuuge Cradllle
And I need to bring them all back here and craft them.
Or I need to craft them all in my own little doodader over there.
But there doesn't seem to be anything here
Unless you're something...
NO YOU'Re NOT!
Justa hole- Ooh
A cave buush. ;)
Thats not important!
Thats not we're looking for right here!
There are also various-
What are you?
Oh, YOU'RE JUST A PLATFORM! (:o how rude, Mark!)
You're a- you're a slab of concrete!
Everyone, let it be known that
Markiplier was enticed by a slab of concrete.
Anyway, so I've glanced around
And there really isn't anything else here,
that is gatherable.
I think...
What I think is...
It's a blue barnacle 'cruster'.
Do I care about that?
(Markimoo's failed attempts at karate)
GIT SOME! Get Rekt
Oooohh
I'm slizzling ya!
So what I think is like
this is intended
as like an
(Allllll or Ollllld)
Big ol' doo dader thing
where you got to go back
and do a hole buncha bulls%&$.
AND I MAY BE MISTAKEN
AND I MAY BE A HORRIBLE IDIOT HERE-
but then again,
that's what I've been the whole time this game and it's not going to be any different.
But what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna going to try to go back up there.
I don't know if im actually going to make it, because the benefit being..
There erriz (?)
Der izz, (mark wtf)
Port-als!
HAAAAAAAA
I think I'm gonna make it,
I got the upgraded jet, so I better be able to make this if I don't make this-
OOOOOOH
COM ON! ;)
(?)
Blap!
Oh f*ck.
Get this in (?)
Heee he he.
Okay, cool.
So, there are portals that lead to
all the other areas
in this entire little...
place.
Cause, what I got to do now is
I got to go out to the various different biomes
because
I haven't even been able to find out
where these seeds are.
From the wiki.
So it's kinda
gonna be an exploration thing
but I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure that each one of these here
Portals...
They point me in the right direction
to be able to get everything that I need.
And I haven't activated them,
So I gotta go activate some-
So I kinda gotta be like,
'Yes.'
'Wherever it pops me, itz gonna pop me'
So I gotta do a little navigation bah hand here.
(Half singing) And if I do that,
Then I'll be happy!
F*ck.
Alright, you carry on
(Half singing again) Imma shove my green thing inside you...;)
That sounds sexual!
But it's not.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Now I go inside this
Big ol' green butthole.
AH!
Am I going to be in a cave
or am I going to be in the middle of the nowhere?
Wheeeeeeere was this?
Ooooh did nilly-
Woah, where am I?
ooOOOOOH
WHAAAAT?
I didn't even know you were here!
Eugh.
Don't you mess with me bruh!
I'm not in the mood to be messed with-
in fact I'm never in the mood to be messed with.
Yeah, I didn't even know this one was here.
Ah! Okay, you don't like me.
Yeeeeee Umpitty
There ARE four portals.
Four portals, four seeds,
makes sense, convenient game mechanics.
Lemme just go to through this one,
'cause I gotta remember, and then I'm gonna drink some piss
and then we're gonna be good to go. -great plan mark-
'Cause, the big problem is, that my cyclops is
down SUPER deep down there.
SO, other- either, I have to...
bring it back up to the surface,
OR,
I can bring it back up to THIS point
..But I think that must be- Wooah, okay alright.
Nightlight out then.
Uh, but that one must be what it is.
When it says-
muh-mem- moOOUmbrain tree,
That MUST be the big ass piece of shit
that was up over here!
And then I can use the portals now because,
they're all activated,
then I should be able to go where I need to go.
But that could answer my questions.
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pack up my bags,
in my good old...
my good old uh- cyclops over there.
And then I'm gonna go through the valley of death again,
and the fire and the flames and the dubstep,
to be able to get back to where I can get, like,
at least around. Because now that I've got the portals,
all I gotta do, is I gotta get my cyclops
the F*ck outta here.
'cause, I don't want it to be down here any more.
Also that means I can bring my cyclops.
Or my Seamon
I can get bubble butt again, I pissed myself in joy!
The reason i'm not just immediately going out
and uh..
I uh.. of, Hi buddy
The reason i'm not just immediately going out and just uh,
going to get those things
each one at a time through all the portals
is because
there are other things in this update
that I wanna see, there is a special surprise
that I am going to head for as soon as I get back
to the surface. Here we go seems clear
euhhhh
I can't believe Bubble Butt (Gibberish)
Big Box Barry... I can't believe Big Box Barry
Ohhhh... Hi, friend!
Ta-daaaa!
I still got-ah my hitchhiker with me
But, you know, it's fine.
Uhhhhh k, whatever.
(Half-singing) Diddily-Doo, I'm running away now
Skiddly-doo
Whoooo's about to hit me?
Someone's not too happy about where I am
but now, comes the arduous journey of
GETTING THE F*CK OUTTA HERE!
Why are you coming over here? (x3)
WHYYYYYYYYYYY
I AM SILENT
I SAY AS I'M SCREAMING!!!!!!!
Ok, we're fine. :D
(A lot of Uh-Ohs)
(Monkey sounds with singing nonsense, Markimoo is in trouble.)
That guy got blasted into his ass! :D
(Half-singing) Holy f*cking sh*t why am I following you?
Go away pleaseeee!
Oh f*ck youuu
Okay putting up my shield for no reasonnn...
Okay, hi welcome
(Sexy alien voice) What.. are.. you?
I'm Markiplier you know big b*tch baby by definition y' know its uh, a good life that I live.
Alive so don't... Don't do that again
I already answered your call so...
(Pirate voice attempt) Thar she blows
Oh, she's so BEautiful!
SO BEAUTIFUL!
Come to me, come to me
I need a seed from you,
can you help me?
Can I seduce you? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Can you just...start producing seeds? (Birds and the bees, Mark)
So, if there ever were...
a membrane see (wtf Mark)
SEED (oh that makes sense)
I would think that it would be from this yar' tree,
that looks MEMBRANOUS
I mean this looks super important
so,
you'd think
you would think
that this would be
ah,
something to do with that.
Oh, ha, ee
GOTCHA!
GOT EM'!
Alright, well...  yeah I DON'T KNOW...
oh, man it was a good thought,
but I guess noooot.
Allllright
if I'm wrong about this,
It'll make me come back to this,
like just tell me in the comments.
I didn't see anything ,
but then again maybe I didn't look hard enough.
But either way ONWARD!!!
INTO GLORY!!!! :D
Ugh, there still on my ass,
one seems to be  riding underneath me ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I probably got 'em grinding right under my tire, here.
Just (failed car attempt)
I'm going this way because I need to get closer
to my base and actually get my sea moth.
(Mark wows in amazement/ horror I can't tell)
Mark?
U ok?
Close your mouth, dammit.
Oh
I didn't even think that he might still be here.
oh,
I had forgotten about you.
Ah,
You are going to be a problem for me, oh no...
Oh no
F*ck tha- you... you are not
Oh no don't you f*cking dare
You're looking right at me
Don't do it (x3)
(Screams in terror)
YYYAY! :D
YAY YAY YIPPIE
YOOOOO!!
Ah-ha-ha owww!
F*cking he's got me PINNED!
HE"S GOT ME PINNED!!!!
Oh my god (x3)
I can't get out.
Ohhhhhh my god
Let me out (x2) STOP PINNING MEEEEE!
Okay, I'm outta here.
Robotic voice: Ahead Flank (Mark copying) urgency speeed.
F*cken that asshole
Yee (x12)
Oh, the tight squeeze ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
the tightest speeze going at it full speed! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Which is always smart.
aaaand we're freee
NO we're not free D:
WE"RE FREEEEE!!!
HOORAY
Good job, me!
I did it. Where's my sh*t?
Where's all my garbo?
Where's all my landmarks?
Woo, hi okay hello.
Where's my sea moth?
THERE it is, there's my stuff over there.
Why am I not- uh... Why am I not getting a beacon for that?
(Mark's terrible yodeling)
OOOO Bubble Butt you're out of your dock!
Why are you out of your dock?
Why are you  out of your "hickory-dickory" dock?
Uh-oh
Latched onto nothing.
There we go.
Robotic voice: Welcome abroad, captain.
(Half-singing) Yeey,
and amazingly this place still has power.
So we got thi-is,
So we got the pressure compensator
imma take that, because that can survive up to 900 anyway,
and I shouldn't acually need to go 900 anymore.
(Half-singing) And the-en Bumble Bu-utt!
Oh Bummmmmble Butt!
(High pitched) Noooo
Awwwww...
Anyway we're going to put the MEGA pressure compensator
onto there.
We don't need this one there but I'll leave it in
because I feel like it.
Ohh and Bumble Butt....
Robotic voice: Welcome abroad captain.
(high-pitched screaming that's making my ears bleed) Bumble Butt!
Goooooooooo Bumble Butt so cuuute...
Ugh, how can I forget you, Bubble Butt?
Oh my god you're not charged up!
Well get in your do-ock!
Alright, you lap?
It wasn't even charging!
Why wasn't it charging?
It was taking all the powe-
What are you taking power from?!
Get outta here!
GET OUTTA HERE!
Alright, whatever. That's more like it.
You're so faaaaast!
I've missed you!
I missed you so much! (true love)
ALRIGHT.
So all that aside,
I know that was a long way to get a not a lot a whole lotta something (english much?)
BUT there was an objective out here,
and the last thing imma do in this episode
is I'm going to find,
the LOOST life-pod
the life-pod 7
is oover...
...somewhere... here
I don't really remember where...
but SOMEWHERE over here,
...exists a life-pod with a very...
...VERY special item inside.
So I'm gonna follow
these until I make my way to the crag fields,
where it is.
Now I don't know the specific location but I'm just gonna,
take a little joy ride with Bumble Butt here
and we're going to have a fun time anyways.
SORRRY
EXCUSE YOU.
(Half-singing) So I gottta keep an eye out
(Singing) I goooot to keep an eye out!
Ooop!
NEVERMIND! It's right there!
HELL YEAH!
Get out of my way beo-otch!
So in this, ah...
in this lovely life-pod here...
is a very special suprise.
There's... a toy car.
Number one.
Theres...a sample that...
BUT ALSO...!
MEEEE!!! :D
AN UNSUAL DOLL! :D
It's right here!
And I have it forever!
Or at least I can make it, right?
That what it is?
Oh THERE it is.
(Little chuckle) Hull plates
'An unusual doll'
'Glass and titanium'
Yeah that sounds about right.
Yee, someone's not happy about that.
Abandon (gibberish) and oooo... gray cap okay alright
I gotta a whole bunch of bull sh*t here.
Just let me get into my boat and get outta here.
Bumble Butt (half-singing) we are outta here,
we got exactly what we needed
Doodle-doodle doo.
(A bunch of doodles)
Ahhhh, f*ck. D:
So, I'm not going to park you in there
because apparently you drain too much power.
What I AM gonna pop in here,
I'm gonna find me some glass
I don't know if I HAVE any glass
Do I have any- OH
I know what I can do to get glass
I can DISASSEMBLE
these (chuckles) things here
I don't know why I still have them there but...
Yeah I can get the quartz out of that and if I get two quartz
Oh, I already got two quartz never mind then.
I'll just salvage another one of these and that one I'll leave there for posterity...
Lemme make the gla-ass right there...
Is there something in here that I could make?
Miscellaneou-OHHH!
OH MY GAWD HE MOVES! :O
That's...not natural but okay!
I'm just gonna have him standing in the middle of this hallway
because it seems like the only place appropriate place for him.
Oh god
(chuckling) Oh god!
HEEEY! (x2)
It's me! :D
I can scan him again!
OH Shi-i-it!
I scanned him into oblivion!
What the f*ck?!
MY GLASS WENT AWAY!
Aw f*ck you-ho-ho!
Mmmmmmm-BOOP!
Look at him! (x2)
Look at him! <3
Let me deconstruct him to see if that actually gives me the thing
OKAY it did.
Let me see if I can put him up on like...
this ahhh I wish I could put him up there.
Can this work? Oh it can!
(Various grunting noises)
Eeeh!
YEAH!
YEAH!!
(High-pitched) YEAH!!! LOOK AT ME!
Oh, that's so cool!
Oh that's so cool!
Anyway,
so that's where I'm going to end this episode
in the next episode I have the objective of finding
these seeds. So f you know where they are
and, your not goofin' me,
let me know down in the comments below.
I know the portals probably
lead to them so I need that as a basis.
But either way,
THANK you all so much for watching
thank you developers
for putting this adorable doll into the game.
And AS always
I will see YOU
in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!!
That honestly looks creepy tbh
I'm going to have nightmares
These subtitles took me two days to do.
Jk, you don't care.
Okay I'll shut up
bye :D